why equals 1/3 absolute value of x plus
4 minus 1 now what you want to pay
attention to is that the general form
okay of the absolute value function okay
the y equals absolute value of x would
be written like this it'll be y equals a
times the quantity X minus H the
absolute value of that plus K now that h
and the K are what shift the graph left
and right up and down okay
the number this group with the X that's
going to shift the graph in the left and
right the X direction but it has the
opposite effect of the sign here so if
this was X minus 2 would actually be
shifting positive so to the right to if
it was X plus 2 then actually going to
the left 2 okay so with me so far
and then this K value if it's positive
it's going to go up and negatives gonna
go down so the same as the sign if it's
positive it's going up negative it's
going down and then this e value here in
front this is what's stretching the
graph if it's greater than 1 compressing
or shrinking the graph vertically if
it's between 0 & 1
and if it's negative that's going to
reflect it over the x-axis so going back
to number 1 you can see that this graph
is being shifted left 4 and down 1 2 see
the plus 4 that's actually having the
opposite effect the left 4 so what we're
gonna do here is let's zoom in a little
bit on this so we can see little bit
better see how about 200% okay let's go
down here to this graph so you can see
basically what we're doing is we're
shifting left four two three four down
one we're gonna think of that point
right there okay as our shifted origin
like our new starting point then what
we're going to do is we're just gonna
focus in on the parent function this
part here y equals one-third absolute
value of x we're gonna make a table of
values okay and we're going to plot from
that shifted origin right there so let's
pick some easy values let's just say for
example like negative 6 negative 3 0 3 &
6 okay so now absolute value of negative
6 is 6 times 1/3 is going to give us
positive 2 absolute value of negative 3
gives us positive 3 times 1/3 is 1 0 is
0 times 1/3 is 0
three gives us 1 and 6 gives us 2 so now
what we're going to do is we're going to
from this point we're going to plot
these coordinates so negative 6 comma 2
we're going to go left 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 up
to right about there and negative 3 1 1
2 3 1 right about there let's see and if
we go right 3 up 1 & 4 5 6 up to right
about there so now you can see this is
our this is our graph it's gonna go like
this ok and like this and see how it has
that V shape to it so the absolute value
graphs they always have that real sharp
corner that v-shape whereas the
parabolas they have that like u shape to
it that you should curve so this is our
graph here if they're asking you for the
domain this is going to be all real
numbers it's going to left and right
they ask you for the range you can see
that the Y values are gonna be greater
than or equal to negative 1 so that's
the idea let's look at another example
so let's maybe cruise on down to let's
just say like for example number 4 over
here okay so for or you can see that
we're working with a square root
function now right so what do you think
on this one well what do you think the 3
does to the graph ok well if you said
left 3 you're right because this has the
opposite effect and what about the minus
1 ok the minus 1 is just down right so
this is going to basically be going left
3 okay so 1 2 3 down 1 so right about
there we're gonna think of that as our
starting point okay and then now we're
just gonna focus in on what's left okay
this is what's called our parent
function ok y equals negative 2 square
root of x we're gonna make a t-chart ok
little table like so and we're gonna
pick values that are easy to take the
square root of for example 0 1 4 & 9
right ok so the square root of 0 is 0
times negative 2 is 0 square root of 1
is 1 times negative 2 is negative 2
square root of 4 is 2 times negative 2
is negative 4 and square root of 9 is 3
times negative 2 is negative 6 now
notice that the two what the two is
doing is it's actually stretching the
graph vertically okay and then the
negative is actually reflecting it over
the x-axis so let's see what that looks
like we plot from this point
zero-zero that's right here let's see 1
negative 2 that's right here 4 negative
4 that's gonna be let's see right about
1 2 3 4 right about there ok and so on
and you can see what's happening with
this graph here we go do one more so
let's be let's see 5 6 7 8 9 great about
there ok so you can see this graph looks
something like this ok and just remember
when you're graphing a y equals square
root of x that has this shape originally
right the 2 is stretching it so it's
going up like x 2 all the Y values and
then what the negative here is doing is
reflecting it so now it's looking
something like this great and then now
the positive 3 and the negative 1 is
actually taking this graph here and
shifting at left 3 and down 1 and that's
how we're getting the graph that you see
on a coordinate axis right there so
let's go take a look another example a
different type of graph this time let's
see what else we have in here let's see
how about how about this one number 5
this is a little bit different so this
is y equals 5 absolute value next - I'm
sorry not the absolute value y equals 5
divided by the quantity X minus 2 plus 1
so here you can see what is the negative
2 gooing of the graph and what's the
wandering to the graph ok what do you
think on that one so if you said it's
shifting right to your right and up one
you're right ok so that's going to be
like our starting point and it's good to
know what the parent graphs look like so
if you want to graph y equals a over X
and let's just say that a is positive ok
then the the graphs gonna look something
like this it's gonna be a hyperbola and
the two branches of the graph are going
to be in the first and third quadrants
ok of course the 5 here is gonna stretch
it by 5 it's gonna multiply the Y values
by 5 and then we're shifting it right to
enough one but we're gonna do now is
we're just going to focus on the y
equals 5 over X part we've already taken
the shift into account so we're just
gonna make a table on what's left over
here ok so let's plot some easy numbers
how about for example like negative 5
negative 1 positive 1 and positive 5 so
let's see so 5 divided by negative 5 is
giving us negative
five over negative 1 is negative 5 5
divided by 1 is positive 5 and 5 divided
by 5 is 1 and now we're going to plot
these coordinates from here now
important thing to recognize is that
with this reciprocal function that the
graphs getting closer and closer to the
x and y axis so those are the asymptotes
so what I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna
draw in our asymptotes and notice that
our asymptotes also shifted to the right
2 and up 1 okay so let's go ahead and
plot those in there can I draw that in
there like so okay so then from this
point we're gonna go left 5 so let's see
2 3 4 5 down once we right about there I
let's see you left one down 5 1 2 3 4 5
right about there so you can see this
branch of the graph is looking something
like this ok a little bit more smooth
okay and then from this point we're also
going to go right one and up 5 1 2 3 4 5
and also right 5 up 1 so 1 2 3 4 5 1
right about there when the graph gets
closer and closer tools asymptotes but
it doesn't touch doesn't cross so are
you starting to see that the pattern
here so what you're doing is you're
looking for that number that's that
group with the ax okay and that's gonna
shut the graph in the X Direction
opposite from the sign then you're
looking at the other value that's added
or subtracted adding it's gonna shift up
subtracting is gonna shift down then you
take whatever is left and you make a
table and you plot from that shifted
starting point that shifted origin so
there's a lot more different examples on
this worksheet
I think there's 12 in total and I'm like
I said I've got the answer key so if you
want additional practice go ahead and
get that worksheet for my teachers pay
teacher's store I'll have the link down
there otherwise let me know what you
thought of this video just a little bit
different format from my normal
whiteboard videos still my same goal for
you to help you you know boost your
score in your math class and make
learning math a lot less stressful and
you know help you to really excel with
your math so let me know in the comments
if this video is helpful or if you
prefer my whiteboard videos or if you
can give me some constructive feedback
that appreciate but again I hope this
helped you and I look for
see you in the future videos I'll talk
to you soon